klé solidaire c'est le but de
l'association en vie elle dispose
d'antenne à travers la France et depuis
peu à trrape son activité est double
réparer et traiter les déchets
électroménagés et accompagner les
personnes en réinsertion avant de
recevoir les responsables d'envie sur le
site de trappe voici déjà les
explications Antony resh et Patrick
Jacques de dixmud mécanicien de
formation Bruno marchand ne travaillait
plus depuis 5 ans le corps trop abîmé
par le travail enve une entreprise de
réinsertion implantée à trappe lui a
permis de retrouver un emploi pour 5
mois et de se former à un autre métier
on essaye les machines avant avant tout
faire on les démonte tout à nu et on
remonte c'est une chance très bien ça me
plaît en
plus vous êtes content ah ouais très
bien l'association reçoit chaque jour 4
à 5 tonnes de matériel électroménagé de
fournisseur un tri est opéré entre les
appareils réparables non avant qu'il
soit révisé pour être mise en vente
autant de postes de travail qui offr une
seconde chance ch Camara arrivé en
juillet espère déjà être prolongé c'est
un contrat pour les personnes qui sont
resté plus de 5 mois ou 6 mois au
chômage comme moi d'accord donc là ça a
permet de de se relancer dans le domaine
professionnel de l'emploi et par la
suite voilà voilà et par la suite
évoluer grâce à l'association envie 11
personnes ont obtenu un contrat
d'insertion professionnel mais cela ne
doit pas s'arrêter là notre objectif
avec le suivi que l'on fait c'est de
pouvoir leur offrir et le les aider dans
leur démarche à trouver un CDI voilà PIR
un CDD de plus de 6 mois ou une
formation qualifiante envie réinsère
dans le monde du travail mais offre
aussi des appareils à moitié prix par
rapport au produits neufs vendus en
magasin et avec une garantie d'un an
face aux demandes des futurs clients la
partie magasin est déjà mise en place
dans la zone industrielle de trapppel en
cours mais l'ouverture officielle est
prévue pour le 6
octobre de nouveaux invités sur le
plateau du 78 Jean Michel lucioto
bonsoir vous êtes le directeur du site
envie sur traape et puis gu Villin
président de l'association envie à traap
donc on va déjà commencer par bien
préciser justement comment ça fonctionne
cette activité vous récupérez
l'électroménager vous le recyclez vous
le mettez en vente c'est aussi simple
que ça euh simple en extérieur c'est
qu'il y a toute une organisation
derrière effectivement on récupère entre
4 et 5 tonnes par jour donc à peu près
80 90 appareils ces appareils sont pesés
parce qu'il y a une traçabilité on est
partenaire avec écosystème donc il y a
toute une traçabilité des produits ils
sont triés donc une fois qu'ils sont
triés donc il y a à peu près une
vingtaine de pourent qui va être rénové
le reste repart dans la filière
démantellement écologique ceux
effectivement qui sont à garder à
rénover sont donnés effectivement au
niveau des opérateurs et vous le
récupérez d'où ce matériel c'est
électroménager au près des grands
groupes des alors effectivement on
travaille avec écosystème qui est un
organisme qui gère effectivement ce type
de déchets entre guillemets et nous
particulièrement on travaill avec Dary
sur la plateforme de beson voilà puisque
les volumes étaient suffisants pour nous
pour Don d'idée en année pleine 2013 on
va collecter entre 1000 et 1100 tonnes
ce qui est prévu là la boutique va
ouvrir le 6 octobre parce que le but
derrière c'est de le vendre à bas prix
hein également voilà puisque c'est ce
qui permet aussi de faire vivre
l'association envie vous avez récolé
combien pour l'instant on voit justement
quelques images du matériel du matériel
200 tonnes pour l'instant 200 tonnes
donc avec les activités qui ont commencé
déjà cet été mais l'ouverture de la
boutique on le précise c'est au mois
d'octobre tout à fait voilà les salariés
alors on va parler des salariés aussi
eux ils sont en insertion
professionnelle on a entendu quelques
témoignages tout à l'heure on peut
peut-être parler du profil des gens qui
qui viennent vous voir et qui
travaillent chez vous parce que il est
là aussi le but de d'envie dans notre
personnel il y a les permanents don
directeur le responsable technique un
chauffeur chargé d'accompagnement et un
vendeur effectivement une dizaines de
personnes en insertion qui sont des
personnes éloignées de l'emploi qui nous
sont envoyés par les partenaires locaux
qui travaillent sur les
personnes le pli pour l'emploi la
Mission Locale éventuellement d'autres
structures d'aide à la personne comme ça
et quels sont les justement quel est le
type de de profil que vous pouvez
recevoir sont des personnes qui ont eu
du mal à trouver beaucoup on du mal à
avir troué du travail ou il faut savoir
effectivement que c'est c'est quand même
très réglementé puisqueeffectivement on
on a une convention avec l'État déjà et
avant que chaque embauche on est obligé
de demander un agrément au Pôle emploi
pour bien vérifier que la personne qui
est pressentie corresponde aux critères
qui sont demandés alors de façon simple
c'est gens qui sont soit au RSA soit en
chômage de longue durée soit des
personnes qui ont des qui est
particulière pour se réinsérer dans le
milieu professionnel qui rentre pas dans
les deux cas précédents c'est en gros le
il sont pas des gens qui sont au chômage
depuis peu he ce sont grand grand
difficulté professionnell en grande
difficulté alors elles sont recrutées
pour 2 ans au maximum alors sont des
contrat minimum de 4 mois hein donc
actuellement on fait des contrats de de
5 mois on peut les renouveler jusqu'à 2
ans mais le but si vous voulez c'est pas
de garder les gens de 2 ans il y a une
autre quand même à d'autre objectif
c'est de pouvoir les aider à retrouver
donc un emploi stable c'estàd un CDI ça
c'est le rêve un CDD depis de 6 mois ou
alors une formation qualifiante
aujour'hui combien de personnes vous
avez sur le site de alors actuellement
on a 11 CDD donc insertion il y a un 12è
qui va rouler c'est band deinertion
qu'on qu'on recherche qui arrive bientôt
et on est 5 permanents vous permettra
d'accueillir au maximum combien de
personnes à plein régime alors à plein
régime il est prévu pour l'année 2013 en
fonction de des accords avec la direct a
possib c'est d'accueillir une vingtaine
18 producteurs alors producteurs plus
effectivement des agents de quai on
serait aux alentours de 35 personnes
avec les permanent envie existe depuis
1984 la première antenne c'était du côté
de Strasbourg une formule qui a déjà
fait ses preuves quels sont les
résultats obtenu justement est-ce que
les les gens derrière retrouvent du
travail est-ce que ça vraiment ça ça les
aide il y a un suivi de ça pe-être il y
a en gros un milliers de personnes qui
passent dans les structures en vie par
an en insertion et à travers la France à
travers la France bien sûr et je crois
si je me trompe pas il y a entre 50 et
60 % de personnes qui sortent avec ce
qu'on appelle une sortie positive c'est
donc soit un CDI soit un CDD de moins 6
mois soit une formation qualifiante ce
sont des résultats que vous jugez
encourageant justement parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de difficultés des résultats
qui sont contenus des situations
économique dans C dans les régions très
honnêtes parce qu'il faut tout reprendre
à zéro aussi avec les salariés que vous
prenez cha salarié est un cas différent
donc pour certains le chemin est très
long pour d'autres il est moins long
tout dépend des situations parce
qu'avant de donner une formation vous
apprenez surtout à venir à l'heure au
travail par exemple prend un c'est ça
comment ça se passe concrètement pour un
salarié qui débuterait demain en
insertion en réinsertion je mais
effectivement les les premières journées
ça va être arrivé à l'heure prendre sa
place dans un groupe ce qui est
pasisment simple pour des gens qui sont
très éloignés de l'emploi voir depuis
plusieurs années reprendre les bons
réflexes d'un emploi et petit à petit
apprendre des gestes professionnels
parce que bon démonter nos appareils les
remonter changer ce qui ne va pas dedans
c'est pas aussi simple que ça ne paraît
ça demande des GES qui sont
professionnels et pour fonctionner tout
ça a besoin d'argent donc le matériel
qui est revendu permet de financer
permet le fonctionnement il y a aussi
des subventions qui vous sont versé tout
à fait à ce jour nous sommes aidés je
dirais par tout toutes les strates qui
peuvent exister la commune de trappe
nous subventionne la communauté
d'agglomération également le Conseil
général on espère que ça va tomber
inamment sous peu le conseil régional
nous aide et l'État par le biais des
contrats aidés nous aide aussi donc tout
le monde nous aide plus un certain
nombre de fondations privées et je
dirais que même les industriels
regroupés dans laazat l'association
syndicale de la zone de Trapil en cours
nous nous aide également
l'électroménager que vous demandez que
vous allez vendre en général ça se vend
bien est-ce que les gens viennent aussi
parce que c'est ça aussi l'important bah
nous avons démarré quelques ventes sur
le bouche à oreille et quelques articles
qui sont parus dans la presse les gens
nous trouvent donc nous espérons à
partir du 6 octobre il faut nous trouver
encore un peu plus mais c'est vrai que
nous sommes dans une zone d'activité et
qu'il faudra déployer de l'effort pour
les faire venir en tout cas êtes-vous
prêt acheter votre électroménager
d'occasion c'est la question que nous
vous avons posée aujourd'hui dans les
rues de SaintQuentin en evveline c'est
notre question du jour achetez-vous
d'occasion l'lectroménager on écoute oh
éventuellement éventuellement je suis
pas contre mais bon j'aime bien UF quand
même
pour je j'ai plus je trouve que j'ai
plus isant mais bon c'est vrai peut-être
que maintenant l'électroménager
d'occasion est bien bien réparé bien
remis en état mais j'ai pas testé non je
préfère acheter neuf parce que on a le
la
garantie et si ça tombe en panne on a
pas de garantie avec de d'occasion
non parce que au moins neuf on a un
recours tout de suite surtout que je
vais vous dire je fais toujours au dans
la même au même endroit et je prends un
contrat de garantie pourquoi pas je l'ai
jamais fait mais j'ai rien contre qu'on
trouve des choses moins chères voilà et
que ça permet de de pasacheter certaines
choses pourquoi pas de l'occasion si si
l'occasion est bonne et puis si si ça
fonctionne bien il y a pas de raison oui
d'occase après moi j'ai mon nom qui est
dans par exemple dans dans ce dans cette
branche où il fait l'électroménager de
seconde main et très bien je crois non
pourquoi parce que si je le change c'est
pour longtemps et donc je prends UF au
départ je sais pas mais je pense que non
alors jusque- là on acheté neuf mais
c'est pas un problème on peut acheter
d'occasion on le fait pour les vêtements
beaucoup on le fait pour les meubles
donc
l'électroménager je pense que oui VO une
cliente potentielle qu'on vient
d'entendre éventuellement qui pourrait
se tourner vers l'association envie du
côté de de trappe alors on a entendu
tout à l'heure juste pour rebondir sur
le micro tretoir la question de la
garantie vous garantissez aussi oui les
produits sont garantis 1 an et comment
ça se passe
alors la personne s'il y a une panne
puis pas arver ben on on intervient on
répare et voilà et ça et ça repart alors
aussi une chose la période
d'immobilisation he si a une pisation du
fait de la panne prolonge d'Ant prolonge
d' temp la garantie ça c'est on a une
garantie d'un an on a aussi en plus une
garantie optionnelle de 1 an
supplémentaire moyenant un coût de 30 €
la personne peut se garantir 2 ans je
reviens sur un point effectivement
l'occasion c'est important c'estd qu'on
a l'impression que l'occasion c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas très propre
qui n'est pas voilà vos équipes de AG
ont vu les produits paraissent neuf
voilà puis on le voit sur les images
c'est comme dans un magasin classique on
va dire ça c'est clair ça ressemble à un
magasin classique alors c'est un vrai
modèle économique que vous avez mis en
place vous dégagez des bénéfices des bah
on n pas encore ouvert donc globalement
c'est une structure la France c'est une
structure oui c'est une structure qui
qui est viable puisqueeffectivement le
le passé le démon puisquil y a 40
entreprises dont la plus ancienne vous
en avez parlé Strasbourg qui a plus de
25 ans c'est un modèle économique qui
est fiable l'enjeu effectivement pour
Trump comme disait Guy c'est de faire
venir les gens et on s'aperçoit que on
n'est pas encore ouvert il y a pas eu
beaucoup de communication tous les jours
actuellement il y a entre trois et
quatre personnes qui viennent sans
quasiment enfin il y a eu un petit peu
le journal de trum il y en a eu quand
même le petit Quentin voilà mais il y a
pas eu vraiment le on n pas déployé
effectivement le toute l'artillerie en
tout cas il y a une attente déjà voilà
orille se fait on fait des ventes et
vous devriez avoir du monde donc pour
l'ouverture le 6 octobre 6 octobre merci
d'être venu sur ce pl envie donc du côté
de trappe et puis un site internet hein
pour si vous voulez en savoir encore
plus sur sur l'initiative qui est menée
depuis 1984 maintenant et qui va débuter
du côté de trappe merci à vous le 78 se
poursuit sur TVfil en direct he toujours
si vous nous suivez entre 18 et 19h la
suite de cette édition du 25 septembre
ce sera avec la page environnement de
Maxime lemen qui nous parlera des
agriculteurs inquiet pour leur avenir et
puis également de la culture découverte
de l'artiste yvelinois MC tir qui sera
en plateau juste après ce reportage
consacré à l'opération sentez-vous sport
le sport c'est la santé un dicton qui a
pris tout son sens à la base de loisir
reportage le sport c'est la santé ce
weekend la base régionale de loisirs de
Saint-Quentin organisé la 2e édition
sentez-vous sport c'est vraiment incité
inciter tout le monde à à avoir une
pratique régulière mais on le on le mixe
aussi avec avec des conseils sur la
diététhique on le mixe aussi avec voilà
une qualité de vie on peut d'ailleurs
faire des des test de forme des test de
forme plus avec la Fédération Française
d'Athlétisme au programme l'élastique
box golf badminton balade en calèche
pour les personnes à mobilité réduite
ainsi qu'une initiation au gestes qui
sauve comme j'ai des enfants qui sont en
basage c'est l'occasion de découvrir des
sports auquel ils ont pas l'habitude
sans oublier le fil rouge de la journée
la marche nordique l'avantage de la
marche nordique c'est de pouvoir
mobiliser l'ensemble du corps tout en
ayant une activité cardioovasculaire
similaire à à celle d'un d'un jogging
une fois que les gens maîtrisent bien la
technique des bâtons l'activité fait de
plus en plus d'adeptes depuis 4 ans tout
comme les rendez-vous sentez-vous Sport
2000 participants sont venus tester leur
forme